check out Deadpool in IMAX swingin that
format is so amazing bigger is better
it's an experience like nothing else
it's just such a great format I was so
happy to see my movie in there this is a
big loud movie it's a really cool
experience to see it and hear it on IMAX
cue the music
that pool is that a larger-than-life
character and every sentient word you
may be wondering why the red suit well
that's so bad guys can't see me bleed I
love that the tone is like almost the
opposite from every other superhero
franchise out there this guy's got the
right idea
he wore the brown pants I will see about
that posh spice it's a character who's
made some wrong decisions and he's
living with those decisions and trying
to be that better person and I feel like
it's very relatable to an audience
dancers only man liver lungs prostate
friend all things I can do without
Riedel is the best that who ever thank
you to the next level the next level of
violence edginess this is gonna kick
open an entire new world for combo moves
a meal best comic book movie ever it's
an experience you like he'll be like
nervous but you think the thing is
coming behind you
you have to see Deadpool in IMAX it was
mind-blowing we've never seen anything
like this the best way to watch it
Deadpool in IMAX bigger better badder
I am very turned on right now